>> Okay. So, it is now
my great pleasure and
an honor to introduce
our chief guest for
today who will be giving
a keynote address today,
Mr. Dnyaneshwar Muley.
I met him at
the prophecy part of
the adivas that was that was
organized by India's Ministry
of External Affairs,
in June this year, focusing
on artificial intelligence.
Mr. Muley is Secretary to
the Ministry of External Affairs
and Indian Overseas Affairs,
but what I found also very
interesting in addition to
all his accomplishments in
the Ministry of
External Affairs is that
he's a very celebrated author.
I understand in Marathi,
but also in Hindi,
and maybe other languages.
In addition, he has launched
educational projects
in his native town,
and so, it's really a great
honor to have him here today,
and I look forward to
your remarks, thank you so much.
>> So, great pleasure
meeting you,
i have just arrived
from the airport,
and sorry to be little late.
Disclaimers first, I'm
not an expert in AI,
so my position is quit safe.
I'm also not a representative
today of government,
any government agency, that's
why my intelligence today
is going to be really artificial.
I'm not holding any key,
some notes yes, but really,
I don't claim to be
a keynote speaker.
My interest would be
really I'm a student,
I'm quite amazed and I'm
no scientific background,
no IT background, otherwise,
I would have used
something very high-tech.
But, I have a deep interest
in this because
anything that is
game changing interest me,
anything that can really,
I'm from a village,
my father was a farmer,
I joined the foreign service
perhaps by fluke,
by chance, but my interest
has always been,
why am I in the foreign service,
type of a question.
Therefore, I always
try to see whether I
can connect diplomacy to people,
that's my focus because diplomacy
is not Minister of
External Affairs in my view,
diplomacy is not South block,
North block, diplomacy is
people, people of a country.
So, just like that,
I know AI or no AI,
it has to be ultimately for
people and for the humanity.
So, that is the basic concern
and being a student,
I read a little bit and
there if I feel that this
is some game changing thing that
is on the horizon, and therefore,
we organize this
conference in MEA,
where we had experts coming
from all over the world,
and we had some
interesting discussions.
So, that's where I start,
I'm not a skeptic,
I'm not suspicious of what
it will do to humanity.
Though in the past any measure
game-changing
technology or effort
has always been seen
with suspicion.
Every now and then we
see a pattern emerge
within technology and
society at large that there comes
along a new understanding
that man has of science,
a new ability to manipulate
the tools in his environment to
his benefit to craft
the world around him
in a new dimension,
and a new possibility
that didn't exist before,
and such moments,
what I called pivot
points change everything,
they accelerate
the evolution of society,
accelerate our culture, help
us overcome all problems,
and create new opportunities,
there's a paradigm shift that
these pivot points have
on society that
becomes undeniable,
they alter the course
of history forever.
Some of the pivot points
in history, for example,
we learned to walk,
man discovers fire,
innovation of the V,
we learned to farm,
we learned to build,
we build the first
pulley systems,
we build the railroads,
two men realize you can sit in
a tin can with wings
and it will fly,
the invention of nuclear power,
the invention of transistors
and silicon chips,
the first telephonic
conversation,
the invention of
the first computer,
the mobile phone,
the invention of smartphone,
Facebook, and now man
marveling at its potential to
be at the cusp of creating
something in its reflection,
yet, other than itself,
an intelligence, that is
artificial intelligence.
Unlike what Hollywood or
fantasy novels would sell you,
the doomsday scenario of
AI taking over [inaudible]
to rather paint a much
different grounded view.
In AI, I see liberation,
though I'm not quite
100 percent sure.
While coming here, I
also had this thought of
this great book by
Francis Fukuyama,
called the Posthuman Society.
This I read sometime in 2013,
and Fukuyama has a very
interesting view of the world,
some of you might be knowing.
He says that, we are
perhaps on the cusp of
being a new species,
humanity, Posthuman Society is
the name of this particular book.
The developments in biotechnology,
genetic engineering,
robotics, precision
engineering, IT,
all this is changing humanity
to certain extent that we
are perhaps likely to become
a different species all together,
that's his conclusion,
if I remember correctly.
Therefore, we need to
have a larger mechanism
to bring some kind of
a basic regulatory
framework for this,
just as we have
a nuclear weapons,
we have weapons of
mass destruction.
Some kind of an international
conversation which creates.
I particularly believe the fact
that it's good to be a humanity,
rather than being something else,
because it's
a great responsibility
now to remain a human,
and in that journey,
I'm actually not sure as to
how AI will play out its role,
will it help us in achieving
a new station in
the evolutionary process or
will it change us completely?
I think that AI is
not specifically mentioned
by Francis Fukuyama,
if I remember correctly,
I had not heard this word,
I know maybe two years back,
I had not heard this word myself.
So, that being the case by us
what he says is now actually,
we're perhaps facing that moment.
So, it's very interesting,
and very fascinating, and
very challenging moment
for all of us.
You might wonder why I
bring up this point,
it is because AI too is
a revolutionary technology,
one that shine some mirror
right in our face,
and for it to truly to be
adopted we must ensure it
permeates our culture in
a way that touches the
lives of billions.
Particularly, billions
is a word which very
suitable for India because
once I was asked
being a diplomat,
how would you describe India?
Actually, everyone has thought
a lot about one's own country,
it often becomes
difficult to encapsulate
it in one sentence
or a few words.
So, I said India is
1.3 billion stories,
and when I look back
I always think that's
a very fairly intelligent answer
because if you see the
diversity, language, culture,
folk songs, people,
costumes, heritage.
It's an absolutely
fascinating playground
for people in AI because
AI has to deal with
very complex things,
including, I think, intuitions
and how do we really come.
So, India that way is
a very fertile ground for
this particular purpose.
Let me clear, I'm not
here to be prophetic or
simply talk in abstract terms as
if I'm pitching you a new idea.
I guess you have already
bought it to the idea,
which is why we are here.
I'm here to get
specific about how
AI can affect daily life and
what can be done to
ensure the proliferation
of this great technology,
so it can truly rise
to its best potential.
Knowledge is best utilized if
it becomes a part of daily life.
That is the true moment of
pivot point for any technology,
where it goes from being
exclusive to becoming
all inclusive.
Facebook, an extremely
exclusive community.
At first, meant only for
Harvard grads, truly took off,
and saw its rise when
the mithaiwala down
the street could
also be on the same platform.
Trust me, he knows
how to use Facebook
just as well as anybody
else in this room.
We as humans tend to be
blind to see well
as anybody else.
We as humans tend to
be blinded to see,
there resides in everybody,
a spark of brilliance,
whatever you can name it,
social brilliance or maybe
singing brilliance or talent.
That brilliance comes
in varied forms.
For some, it is in
writing a great deal.
Some, it is creating algorithms.
For some, it is
building a company.
For some, it's PhD
from IIT or USC.
For some, it is
knowing how to run
the best mithai shop in
the entire Chandni Chowk.
Yet, all of us are
brilliant and intelligent
in our own ways.
If we are supposed to
truly think of benefit
of AI to the society,
we have to first internally
accept everyone is brilliant.
Just because Lalaji
from Chandni Chowk,
who owns the best
mithai shop in Delhi,
never learned how to
write his first line of
code and print
Hello World on C++,
doesn't mean he lacks
the intelligence to make
AI a daily part of his life.
Our friend simply speaks
a different language.
This transaction
between the scientist
and Lalaji breaks down if
the scientist puts the onus
on Lalaji to figure out
how to use AI or to
know the difference between
convolutional neural net
and artificial neural net.
It's like Lalaji asking
a programmer whether to fry
the badam first or
the kishmish for
the halwa to retain
the slightly charred,
but not burnt flavor.
We just want the halwa and
we want it to taste good.
When good technology
doesn't get adopted,
it's a communication
breakdown between
the scientists and the masses.
I believe that anything
that we are doing at
this particular stage in
our evolution has to be
useful to the masses,
which really represent nothing,
but the humanity at its core.
This happens because many a
times, futuristic technology,
they tend to become egalitarian,
reserved only for the elite few.
So, even if something
may have a great impact,
the masses learn to shy
away from such tools,
self subscribing
to the impression
that a certain tool
or technology may be
outside their
comprehension or that
it's something meant to
be in a research lab.
Often, it is the very creators
who end up isolating
their own creations
when they become
subjects of elite praising only.
With that, technologies,
which could have had
a wonderful impact,
end up dying a slow,
painful death versus
mass adoption.
I remember that Akio Morita,
in his Made in Japan,
also had made some very
interesting points about how
a video cassette recorder of
a particular size
survived and how it
did not because they
thought that they
wanted to have
an exclusive product
while everybody else in
the world had adopted
a particular standard and are
producing mass creations.
So, I'm here to give you
context of how AI can
go on to become a
part of daily of
Indians and hopefully give
some perspective on why it
is extremely critical for
AI to proliferate down
to the very grassroot levels
of the society,
outside of standard corporate
environment as well.
It is my hope,
as we start digging deeper,
that the ideas and viewpoints,
I put forth help inspire
the audience members to
truly think outside the box.
For AI proliferation to
happen at the highest level,
we must design AI tools
such that one is able
to use them without
requiring any prerequisite tools
or knowledge or even skills.
Let me give you an example.
There was a time
designing a website was
something you hired a coder for.
It was a luxury afforded only to
the few lucky ones who were
either affluent enough to
have a website or were
literate enough to
navigate the world of CSS,
HTML, or Dreamweaver.
There was a certain set
of knowledge one
required before one could
have their own website.
This changed, however,
with the advent
of Wix, Squarespace, WordPress.
Without having
any knowledge of HTML,
you could drag and drop
elements onto a canvas,
and built out a website,
built out store.
A common entrepreneur with
no special computer
skills could get
an online store up and
running in minutes,
all because tools like Wix and
Squarespace made creating
a website easy and fun.
A website in today's day and
age isn't about a website,
it's about having an identity.
The onus is on
all the stalwarts of AI
present here in this audience
to truly think,
how can we highly functional
drag and drop tools with
such easy user interface
that it could allow
someone with zero coding skills
to deploy AI based apps?
Sure, machine learning
and APT exist,
but I challenge and
implore you to go further.
I'm envisioning a platform
where a child could learn how
to make an AI do
an application even
before he writes code,
simply by using drag and
drop tools on a canvas.
What we are doing here is,
taking the fear out of
AI, making it accessible.
For proliferation to happen,
any of the scary aspects of
AI need to be eliminated.
We have to make AI a
natural part of our lives.
We have to make it
fun and relatable.
I'd like to propose
an extremely practical use case
for AI that is sure to
hit every Indian heart.
Shortly after, I'll follow with
some use cases within
the healthcare sector.
A recent friend of
mine, Seema Aunty,
you all know Seema Aunty,
went through the experience
of hosting a Shaadi.
Ever since then, I have wondered,
how about an AI driven app
for managing the Shaadi,
bringing together
all the vendors,
the flower guy, the
caterer, the tent guy,
the transportation company,
the wedding decorator,
the baker, the bandwala,
the DJ, the lighting guy?
Do you know how many variables
one has to manage?
You are consistently
taking calls,
you have multiple points
of contacts.
One is texting, the other
is calling someone.
Typical chaos and confusion
of Indian marriage.
Prefers email, the
other prefers WhatsApp.
You end up explaining
the same thing over and
over again 10 times
in 10 minutes.
What if I could manage
all these relationships
from one single app,
understand the bottleneck,
see if everything is
running on schedule?
I could even have my invite list
on the same app along
with the card printers.
I could have people
RSVP through the app.
The AI could predict, based
on traffic conditions,
what the flow of
guests is going to be,
what the dietary preferences
of our guests are,
what the most appropriate
frequency to roll out
the appetizers during the wedding
to make sure they don't dry up.
Truly, this can be broken
down into an algorithm.
The USC folks out here
are going to enjoy this.
You can even take into
account air humidity and
moisture to understand the effect
of sponginess of the dhokla,
and the frequency at
which they need to be
rolled out to make sure
the Q factor of
our dhokla is of
the highest caliber possible,
based on real time guest flow.
I could also understand
if the ladkewala invited
more guests than us,
that is ladkiwalas.
By running across
comparison report
of the RSVP origination,
the data doesn't lie.
Who thought Seema
Aunty's new taunt
to her would be son-in-law,
would be the data doesn't lie?
This is such a simple yet
practical use of data science.
This is hardcore data
science on the back end,
but it would be
a dream come true for
anyone who has managed
a wedding in the house.
You'd be alerted of delays,
bottlenecks from any vendor,
along with having a complete
vendor and market place
for best rates for
Shaadi vendors in your area.
You could even arrange a pandit
or a priest, if one needs to.
We could even have
backup vendors ready in
place in case someone was
going to fall through.
I'm sure you could even
have a backup groom,
but that maybe a use case
we omit out of this.
India is a land of weddings,
so let's get people
married more efficiently.
I think particularly
in the IT sector,
it's not very efficient type
or it can't run very efficiently.
I am sure you are
wondering if this is
the best use of your expensive
computer science degree,
there's a reason why
I chose to go with
such an example is because
it does something wonderful.
It makes AI less scary.
Packaging is very important,
I will use Case Packages Concept.
Concepts within AIs such
as Process Improvement,
Process Management
Efficiency Response,
Risk Mitigation,
Predictive Analysis and
Data Analysis into
a very non-scaled,
non-version of
Virtual Studio Manager.
Ultimately, AI is not about
Peter Norvig's of the word
or the very respectable
Harry Xiong,
I don't know how to pronounce it.
Our Indian languages
actually have far
more phonetic and therefore
far more scientific,
then you relate them with how
it is written and how
it is pronounced.
That's can also I'm
told help in IT.
It's about humanity as a whole,
it's about enriching
one's life in a way.
That's why I can't write
my name correctly in
any standard scripts that
are available because
it's in a niche word,
nobody can pronounce it correctly
even in India
outside Maharashtra.
Forget about them
doing it overseas.
So, humanity as
a whole it's about
enriching one's
life in a way that
isn't pretentious but truthful
to the stories of
billions of people.
For C1T, for that
brief moment in time,
the Shaadi becomes
a new universe.
If AI can succeed in making
that small little universe
abide brighter place,
where things just
fall into order,
we are then succeeding.
To give another analogy,
smartphones.
All of us present here know
how to use them and all we're
required to do so is
room- temperature IQ.
The fact that I don't have
a complete understanding
of the components inside
the actual iPhone does not act as
a barrier to my utilization
of the iPhone.
I can use it just as
well as anybody else.
A similar paradigm has to
emerge within AI
for mass adoption.
Moving on and to change
the mood I would like
to get into the
healthcare sector.
I believe some people here are
actually in the
healthcare sector.
India is a uniquely positioned
at the current moment
for healthcare or all.
We also stand to produce
a tremendous amount of
data that can contribute
towards research and,
may I say, real-time
behavioral data for
correlation between
different elements
and lifestyle choices.
The HIPPA healthcare laws
of US designed
with the best intention
in mind of securing
the privacy of the patient have
made Electronic Medical Record,
EMR Industry, in US a
fragmented and disparate system
that is slow to innovate.
So, we must go beyond the
traditional model India hasn't.
India hasn't still adopted
the concept of EMR.
But in many ways,
this fresh start
or rather blank canvas is
a chance to learn from
the mistakes and
successes of others,
before us and truly innovate.
I would like to propose
a two-way EMR system where
the patient and doctor both have
the ability to input data.
Let's take a moment
to think majority
of EMRs right now don't have
the ability to have
a two-way conversation platform
between the patient
and the doctor.
Let's say you had a patient
come in for cancer treatment.
As he starts his treatment,
he's given a
standardized app that
he downloads which
is tied up with
his EMR number much like
another number and he's
put on the cancer regimen.
But as a part of
his healthcare treatment is also
required to voluntarily
log his quality of sleep,
his daily activities,
his daily diet.
This one's for the data.
Scientists in the room whose
wheels are already turning,
now this data is being
collected through
a mobile app on the phone and
every time the patient goes
for his chemo treatment,
the doctor is able
to generate analysis
in real time to see what are
the correlation between
lifestyle choices
and prevalence of
certain types of cancer.
This information is
currently not possible in
real time as a two-way
EMR logging system,
which allows the patient to log
their lifestyles habits and give
doctors real time access
into patients
life is something that
hasn't been deployed.
Doctors can see what is
the correlation between diet
and certain types of cancer.
Are certain types of cancers
more prevalent in
certain zip codes?
Are we seeing an increase
and outbreak of
a certain subtype of
cancer coming from
certain geographical region
with certain lifestyle choices?
I call this an Active EMR,
where the patient actively
takes part in logging
their daily habits,
their calorie count,
their activities of
the day, quality of sleep.
Imagine the leap
healthcare can make when
this data is cross-correlated
in real time.
We're cutting through
all the red tape
of gathering such data.
You have an active
population of a billion
plus participating in
a lifetime study that
evolves and collects data that
goes well beyond
just the confines of elaborate.
Drones have become
a controversial topic.
Ones mind automatically results
to drone strikes and drones as
amusing of man's latest invention
and making a new efficient
killing machine.
On the contrary though,
I'd like to shine some light on
some use cases that have
major impact on healthcare.
Imagine a rural area
where a mother requires
a lifesaving medicine
in the middle of
the night, queuing
drone delivery.
This is not futuristic
or experimental.
The scientists in
the audience are aware that
barring certain exceptions
Machine Vision Algorithms
and Drone Technology are already
mature enough to
perform this feat.
Similarly, given urban traffic
and ambulance is on the way
to see a patient who's calling
for life-threatening
allergic reaction.
The ambulance gets
stuck in traffic
making it impossible to
reach the patient in time.
However, utilizing
drone delivery and made
back with an EpiPen and a
video tablet is dispatched.
The drone arrives at the scene
while the ambulance is
still trying to make its way
through the traffic.
The medic in
the ambulance is video
conferencing the family
of the patient,
walking them through
the steps of administering
the EpiPen saving
the life of the patient.
In a scenario where few seconds
would have mattered,
drones and AI can be
the difference between
life and death.
We all fight our own battles
and sometimes technology can be
a comforting tool to remind
us we are not alone.
I would like to propose
in the application of
AI and helping addicts
quits substance abuse.
How about an AI do
an app to help you
quit smoking, gambling, drinking?
Imagine having an app
that helps you
quit drinking every time.
I think it'll be very
useful in Bangalore.
Every time you are going
out with your friends,
you alert the app you'll
be out with your friends.
The app could also use
location data to see
if you have stopped
by a bar and how long
you are there at bar.
It could keep sending you
push notifications reminding you
to not give in to
peer pressure and the promises
you've made to yourself.
Call it a timed intervention.
If you keep ignoring
the push notifications,
not even checking them,
it could even generate
an automatic call
with a pre-recorded
voice message,
from your friends reminding
you of how you want to quit,
it could even alert
your closest friends to
call you for support and
remind you to stay strong.
I'll often struggle
against some kind of
demon or the other and all
we need to be reminded
at the right times is
we are not alone
in that struggle.
Safety is primary concern of
our public transportation,
in fact Bangalore transportation
can do a lot with the use
of application of funerals.
Where they would take people
out there the traffic
seems to be getting
from bad to worse.
So, I think you need
to come forward
to find out
some complex solutions
to these issues and AI perhaps
can be of great use there.
Safety is primary concern of
our public transportation
utilizing Pose Estimation,
Facial Recognition
and Machine Vision.
We could monitor
our buses especially with
the Algorithmic Sensitivity
turned on to high
during the night
and upon detecting
suspicious behavior the nearest
police station could be
live-streamed the residuals
from the inside of the bus
CCTV to assess whether
a threat is real or not.
We can save lives, we
can keep our women,
children and men safer.
I know there will be a
time where we will predict
epidemics before they happen
and save millions of lives,
I know there will be a time when
our city planning would
lead by generations,
utilizing behavior patterns,
and congestion patterns.
I envision a day where
a child in a rural area
will be able to
remotely program a drone and
use it for smart farming.
Farming because Agriculture
is a huge opportunity
for AI believers and
being a very complex
country as it is,
you have strange agricultural
patterns, weather patterns,
marketing channels,
available, not available,
off-season, on season, drought
years, no drought years.
We can really take this forward
in a huge way in
agriculture is concerned.
Whether that time happens
today or 10 years from now,
is dependent on
our willingness to
understand as innovators that we
must make AI accessible,
fun and easy.
The applications of
AI for benefit of
social good are endless
but the bottom line stays.
It must proliferate to
the very grass-root
levels of society,
we must learn to
speak the language of
the common man and truly make
them see AI as
a friend not a foe.
That's my, more or less,
the talks of the topic.
I'm not sure whether
it makes any sense.
As I said, I 'm a student
and very soon I'm going to retire
and AI is one of my focus areas
particularly higher education.
So, that's why my interest
in this topic,
I think before we embark on
a huge journey we also need
some good awareness in society
and that kind of
education short-term,
medium-term, long-term
courses is I think
a need of the time and
that's where perhaps I might be
focusing some of my energies.
So, Melinda, thank you so
much for inviting
me and all of you,
thank you so much for
being so patient.
I'm not a doctor, I
can't give a remedy
to all the patients,
but let's welcome
this endeavor together
and if I could be of
any assistance in your journey,
I'll be there to help,
assist, support, and
work together with you.
Thank you so. I
really appreciate.